[Music]
at a ceremony in beijing
xi jinping honored those who played key
roles in china's fight to end extreme
poverty nationwide
the president says 717 million people
have been lifted out of poverty
over the past 40 years and for the
second time since december
hailed the achievement as a victory for
the communist party
832 counties and 128
000 villages have been removed from the
poverty list
the odious task of eradicating extreme
poverty
has been fulfilled we have created
another miracle
that will go down in history ending
extreme poverty has been a key goal of
xi jinping's government since it came to
power in 2012.
three million communist party officials
were given targets for improving living
standards in rural communities
they were tasked with going door to door
to document incomes in poor households
beijing then poured billions of dollars
into the building of new homes
schools factories and roads it's a
textbook case
on how to get people out of poverty and
i think
getting people out of poverty is perhaps
the most single important thing that any
state can do
to advance its social economic progress
the united nations has been trying to
reduce extreme poverty around the world
and china says its achievement covers
more than 70 percent of the un's goal
but its benchmark for poverty a daily
income of 2.30
is below the world bank's standard for
higher income countries
critics of the initiative say it's
unsustainable with many villagers
relying on government support to prop up
newly founded industries
and some people have been unable to
adapt to assigned jobs
while others have complained of forced
relocations
this is a much needed win for the
chinese government and it comes at a
crucial time
beijing is pushing to revive the economy
following the pandemic
and in july is marking 100 years since
the founding
of the communist party xi jinping is
hoping this milestone will strengthen
loyalty to the party
as well as its own legitimacy as its
leader
katrina u al jazeera beijing